the easiest way to make the dream of
owning a BMW a reality is to choose the
one series starting at around 23,000
euros in Germany it's served as an entry
to the BMW brand for 150,000 new buyers
making it a key model for the Bavarian
car maker tester Android sim among sites
people who complain that things were
better in the past like more 3 door
compacts with rear-wheel drive and that
those models are now a dying breed but
he says there is still a car that fits
that basic description and that's the
BMW 1-series our 118 D model with the
urban line package starts at around 34
thousand euros in Germany the 8-speed
steptronic transmission makes the 0 to
100 kilometer per hour sprint in 8.1
seconds
the 1-series has a typical BMW exterior
the headlights feature the classic twin
circular design and then there's the
unmistakable two kidney radiator grilles
Fabia Andre says it's logical in a
rear-wheel drive for the engine to be
mounted lengthwise not transverse and
take up more length of the car than
width but actually at 4.30 three meters
this compact BMW is only marginally
longer than the current VW Golf this
engine configuration leaves less room
for passengers and luggage says Andre
but his impression is that there's
plenty of room although not for a long
vacation to be exact the BMW offers 360
litres of trunk space that's just 20
litres less than the golf with
front-wheel drive a difference that most
owners won't mind
the interior is definitely up to BMW
standard even if there is a lot of
plastic here it's of high quality
workmanship and as a pleasant feel
the most noticeable effect of the
rear-wheel drive is on the right - dusty
Andre explains it like this since the
front axle doesn't exert any thrust the
steering stays free from any drive
influence so no matter how much he
accelerates out of the curve the force
exerted on the steering wheel stays the
same that makes for easier handling and
doesn't falsify the feedback he gets
from the steering many drivers of
today's mostly front-wheel drive cars
have never known this kind of handling a
large number of drivers see rear-wheel
drive as a must in sports and race cars
since it means less of a temptation to
understeer at high speeds
[Music]
named Andre points have another feature
that along with the rear-wheel-drive
emphasizes the Beamer one series is
sporting ambitions the 8-speed
steptronic transmission with most
automatics to shift manually the driver
pushes forward to shift up and pulls
back to shift down but here it's the
other way around
Andre sees that as the more logical way
to do it because that's how it works in
race cars with sequential gearboxes so
the shift lever moves in accordance with
the g-forces when accelerating and
braking so it's a logical configuration
but unfortunately it hasn't become the
norm for the great majority of cars
being visits laundry observes the BMW's
1-series occupies a niche that no other
car maker will venture into right now
that may be a very good selling point
but it might not last long
BMW makes plenty of other models that
don't have rear-wheel drive the kinda
got a problem
one harbinger of this development was
BMWs 2 Series active tourer that
utilized a transverse engine with
front-wheel drive to create more space
for the passengers this may very well be
the stars for the next generation of the
1 Series and that would spell the end of
the rear-wheel drive
era for the compact class